ja was bedeuten diese Zahlen was genau
steht dahinter und wo führen Sie uns hin
ich sage guten Abend nach Dresden zu
Professor Werner Patzelt
Politikwissenschaftler von der TU dort
einen schönen guten Abend
Professor patzelte die Schwäche der
ampelpartei in diese zerstrittene
Regierung Einfallstor und Wind unter den
Flügeln für die AFD ist es so einfach
es ist nicht so einfach denn die AFD
hatte ihren Aufstieg von einer den
Einzug in der Bundestag für fehlenden
Partei zur stärksten Parteien
Ostdeutschland der schon zu jedem Zeiten
begonnen als die andere Regierung noch
in weiter Ferne lag und Angela Merkel
das Land regierte der Aufstieg der AFD
ist ein sehr tief hat sehr tief liegende
Ursachen sie haben mit dem zu tun was
man eine repräsentationslücke nennen
kann das nämlich viele in Deutschland
sich von den etablierten Parteien nicht
mehr vertreten fühlen und wenn wie
derzeit die Ampel auch noch die Hoffnung
in ihrer Anhänger nicht zu erfüllen
vermag dann wird die allgemeine Stimmung
einer Unzufriedenheit mit der
politischen Klasse immer immer größer
und nun gehen ja heute auch schon die
Diskussion los wie denn die Wähler von
der AFD wieder zurückzuholen während und
da gucken wir mal auf die Partei auch ja
eher im auf der rechten Seite des
Spektrums steht auf die CDU und die sagt
es gibt ein Potenzial der AFD Wähler das
ist für uns für die CDU gar nicht mehr
erreichbar sehen Sie das auch so
das ist so es hätte als die AFD anfing
immer mehr Leute an sich zu binden die
CDU die Chance zur Einsicht gehabt dass
viele die jahrelang toll zur CDU
gestanden haben sich von der von Angela
Merkel geprägten CDU nicht mehr
vertreten fühlten nach einer neuen
Partei suchten hofften dass das
Aufkommen eine neue Partei für die CDU
eine Art wegsignal wäre und dann haben
sie erlebt dass die CDU nicht im
mindestens daran dachte auf die Sorgen
jeder Leute die für die AFD zu stimmen
begonnen hatten einzugehen sondern dass
man die dann auch noch ganz bewusst als
Faschisten rassistenten dummdeutsche und
so weiter ausgrenzte das heißt im
Klartext viele die die AFD wählen haben
der CDU innerlich gekündigt die CDU ist
für die meisten AFD Wähler die am
meisten verachtete Partei geworden es
gibt keine Chance mehr für die CDU im
nennenswerten Umfang von der AFD stimmen
und die AFD die beschäftigt sich jetzt
ja eigentlich schon mit einer anderen
Partei nämlich Timo kovala der
Parteichef der hat heute gesagt wir
positionieren uns als Gegenpol zu den
Grünen also eine klare
Anti-Haltung dorthin und einen Schritt
weiter als Anti klimaparteien noch mehr
was ja schon immer angeklungen war bei
der AFD
es ist schon seit sehr lange Zeit zu
erkennen gewesen
dass die Grünen und die AFD die einander
am weitesten entgegenstehenden oder
auseinander liegenden Parteien
Deutschland sind bei sämtlichen
Politikern bei denen die Grünen an der
Spitze stehen und glauben das was sie
vertreten sei das einzige richtige ob
das eine offene herzige
Migrationspolitik ist ob das Direktor
des Weltklimas von Deutschland aus ist
ob das früher der Pazifismus und jetzt
die Unterstützung inne im russischen
Krieg ist für alledem war immer schon
die AFD auf genau der anderen Seite und
politische Beobachter haben das nicht
selten dass die Formel gebracht dass die
immer mehr zu den Grünen sich öffnen die
CDU zwischen den Grünen unter AFD
zerrieben würde und man kann die Sache
seitens der grüne nach gerade folgende
Formel bringen die Grünen werden von der
AFD wenigstens gehasst also als Gegner
ernst genommen die CDU wird nur noch als
Opportunisten Haufen verachtet jetzt
müssen wir aber auch über die
Regierungspartei sprechen über die
Kanzlerpartei über die SPD 18 Prozent
dort also gleich auf mit der AFD
was heißt das
das heißt das zwar jedem Anfang ein
Zauber innewohnt und 56% betrug die
Anzahl derer die mit der Arbeit der
Bundesregierung zufrieden waren noch vor
12 Monaten ungefähr das aber irgendwann
der Zauber verfliegt und nachdem sich
grüne und Freie Demokraten in der
ampelkollektion heftig zu streiten über
die sehr wichtigen Politikfelder
Klimaschutz insbesondere und wie geht
man mit dem Staatsfinanzen um wäre
eigentlich seitenste SPD politische
Führung gefragt aber die SPD ist da
ihrerseits wissen eine solche hat die
SPD eine lange Tradition einer sehr
seriösen Regierungspartei die auch
wirtschaftliche Interessen ernst nimmt
die verweisen nur darauf dass der
Wohlstand der zu Angela merkte Zeiten
wie unverrückbar erschienen eine Frucht
der Agenda 2010 Reformen von Gerhard
Schröder gewesen ist aber anderthalb ist
der SPD auch überzeugt von den Grünen
politikprojekten weswegen ist das
Sozialdemokraten ja auch die Grünen in
der Regel als die geborene Partner
betrachtet und das ist dann einfach der
weitere Ausbau des Sozialstaates das ist
die vibrationspolitik das ist die
moralische Vorbildrolle Deutschlands
beim Kampf gegen den Klimawandel so dass
die SPD zerrissen ist zwischen der
Seriosität einer Anpassung an die
Wirklichkeit und dem Streichen der
preisele und da muss ich
verständlicherweise auch ein
führungsversprechender Bundeskanzler
immer wieder zurückhaltend
eine zerrissene Parteienlandschaft eine
profitiert in die afd-professor Werner
Patzelt herzlichen Dank für die
allenschätzung dieser aktuellen Umfrage
des Deutschlands